- [Narrator] Wind whips
over a barren wasteland.
Vast nothingness as
far as the eye can see,
or so it may seem.
Creatures peek out of burrows,
scurry across the sand,
and soar through the sky,
revealing a landscape not as lifeless
as it might first appear.
Deserts are often defined as areas of land
that receive less than 10
inches of rainfall each year.
These regions are low in humidity
and can even be moisture-deficient,
evaporating water faster
than it is received.
While most deserts are
found in the mid-latitudes,
these diverse ecosystems
occur on all seven continents
and make up nearly one-third
of Earth's total land mass.
Deserts are sometimes classified
into four major types:
subtropical, semiarid, coastal, and polar.
Subtropical deserts are
found along the equator,
and the Tropic of Cancer,
and the Tropic of Capricorn.
They are the hottest deserts on Earth,
with daytime temperatures
that can reach up to
120 degrees Fahrenheit.
Semiarid deserts are located in Asia,
Europe, and North America.
These cold-winter deserts often form
when tall mountain ranges block moisture
through a process called
the rain-shadow effect.
Coastal deserts form alongside
the tropical western edges
of certain continents.
Despite their proximity to water,
coastal deserts remain dry.
Polar deserts are found in
the Arctic and Antarctic.
The other end of the extreme,
winter temperatures in
the Antarctic Desert
average around minus
50 degrees Fahrenheit.
While deserts experience
extreme temperatures
and receive very little precipitation,
they are still important
habitats for plants and animals.
Desert animals, such as the coyote,
have evolved to withstand
harsh desert conditions
by burrowing into the cool ground
and emerging at night, when
desert temperatures drop.
Many desert plants,
including the saguaro cactus,
have established long
and shallow root systems
to better absorb what minimal
moisture might be present
in the ground.
Highly specialized to survive
in such a harsh environment,
desert wildlife is particularly vulnerable
to ecological changes.
Existing deserts have
become less habitable
because of rising temperatures
that dry up scarce water resources
and increase the risk of wildfires.
Additionally, new desert
areas are beginning to form
through desertification.
This phenomenon occurs when
factors such as deforestation,
climate change, and resource mismanagement
degrade the biological
productivity of a region,
thereby creating a desert.
For instance, in Central Asia,
poor irrigation practices
and excessive water usage
dried up the Aral Sea
and formed the youngest
desert on the planet.
But by practicing responsible agriculture,
better management of
limited water resources,
and limiting further development,
it may be possible to curb desertification
while protecting our surprisingly
rich desert ecosystems.